steve cohen multi-billionaire owner of
the new york mets but he also is one of
the best traders on wall street as well
and so uh it's fun to kind of think
about him as a sports owner but he built
a very large uh net worth over 11
billion dollars it's estimated um being
one of the best traders what he
ultimately has done in the crypto world
was he's very uh critical of it or at
least uh dismissive and kind of sat it
out all the way up until recently but uh
yesterday at the salt conference he went
out and he basically explained he said
listen
my son who he described as a crypto
maniac convinced him to start looking at
the space and convinced him that steve
and the rest of the folks at point 72
did not miss out on the overall industry
there was still lots and lots of
opportunity there and so inside of 0.72
and also with steve's personal money and
the money that they manage externally
they started to do a whole bunch of
different stuff here so yesterday there
was announcement they invested in
radical spelled radkl it's a
quantitative trading firm for digital
assets uh the entire idea behind that
investment is uh really taking a lot of
the electronic trading ideas and and all
the quant strategies that have worked in
wall street uh in the liquid assets
around commodities and stocks and now
bring that to crypto probably makes
sense for a guy who's done very very
well uh trading there the second is a
couple of days ago or maybe a week ago
they invested in something called recur
it's a company that develops experiences
allowing fans to buy and sell nfts uh
and then also they have now said that
point 72 is building crypto trading
capabilities internally at the firm
itself uh and
about a month ago they also invested and
led the masari i think it was their
series a or b a 21 million dollar
fundraising round for missouri i think
of them as kind of like a bloomberg for
crypto uh really focusing on data etc
and so when you start to see this steve
cohen 65 years old he's got a net worth
of 11.1 billion dollars according to the
bloomberg billionaires index i don't
know if bloomberg or forbes is less
accurate but 11 billion is the estimate
uh and as of march 2021 they had 1500
employees about 22 billion in aum pretty
crazy that about half of the firm's at
um is his
[Music]
and the investment they did in radical
has about 10 employees currently and
they expect to hire much much much more
over the coming days now we've got a
couple of quotes from steve uh one of
these quotes comes from the salt
conference shout out anthony scaramucci
and steve said he speaking about his
crypto maniac uh son really convinced me
this was something i needed to do once i
decided there were opportunities and i
thought this could be a space like the
internet it could be incredibly
transform transformational i wasn't
going to miss this a multi-billionaire
who is regarded as one of the best
investors on wall street saying i wasn't
going to miss this pretty powerful we
got another quote from the .72 letter to
investors and what they said is we can
assure you that we will be prudent in
the nature of and sizing of our
investments both from an allocation and
market standards perspective we do
however believe there's more innovation
and evolution to come into space and we
want to make sure we have a seat at the
table pretty
i think rational thought frankly in
terms of them wanting to go ahead and
enter the space now when you think about
steve cohen entering into the crypto
space i think there's three things that
immediately jumped to mind one is he's
got a lot of capital two is he serves as
a signal for the rest of the industry
other people on wall street saying wow
steve cohen's into this maybe i should
take a look at it similar to paul tudor
jones stanley druckenmiller etc before
him and then the third thing is uh he's
very very sophisticated him and 0.72 and
so their trading strategies their uh
kind of capital markets experience their
ability to leverage their network et
cetera in order to help the companies
that they invest in uh seems to me like
this is a really really big opportunity
um for somebody like this to enter the
market joe and john what do you guys
think about it yeah i mean steve cohen's
a beast
right like he's uh he's obviously done
really well for himself and super
successful i think it speaks a lot to
his ability to adapt over time right and
look at a new industry and say there's
obviously potential here let me take a
deeper look and i think what we've seen
is we've seen that divide occur over the
last 12 to 24 months and actually even
further back of people that are
traditionally seen as the heads of wall
street or hedge funds managers or
whatever it might be saying some of them
are saying hey look this is worthless
all this kind of stuff and some are
saying no actually there's probably
something here i'm seeing some of the
changes that are occurring younger
people that work for me my son in this
case
are telling me that there's value here
let me go take a deeper look so kudos to
steve cohen for taking a deeper look and
not turning it off and saying hey look
there might be something here we'll see
kind of where it leads to down the
investment front uh kind of to be
determined what investments make sense
and kind of how he does on that front
but at least he's kind of getting
involved and not just shutting down a
new emerging industry and trend that is
clearly here to stay yup john you agree
i completely agree with that steve for a
long time has been regarded as one of
the best traders and money managers i
think in the world right um and it does
speak to his ability to keep an open
mind uh a lot of people kind of dismiss
what they don't understand right they
say it's stupid i don't like it
it's not important and all that stuff
right so
using the younger generation like his
kid or anything like that to be able to
like get an insight into this kind of
industry uh i think it's very important
very smart and uh look he's keeping an
open mind we'll see what he does but
he's notorious at uh
being a money manager one other thing
that came up uh there's an article today
that was published on yahoo financed by
annie massa and catherine burton and uh
we know about the crypto element like it
makes sense that somebody who's really
good at trading wants to go and do a
bunch of trading somebody who's good at
investing wants to do a bunch of
investing uh but there's one part in
here that blew me away and it said that
steve cohen is interested in the virtual
realm that extends beyond crypto as well
cohen expressed a fascination with the
metaverse or a vision of a virtual world
where people interact through avatars he
said quote there's some far out ideas
out there about how people are going to
spend their time you can't your mind can
run wild and he specifically said uh
mentioned things like buying virtual
real estate virtual outfits for their
avatars etc and so he said it's taking
me to a different realm uh and owning a
hedge fund you have some notoriety but
nothing like owning a sports team in new
york and so he's very much i think
sitting at this intersection now where
he's got the wall street experience the
investing experience he obviously now
owns a sports team so he's getting more
into like culture and understanding uh
how fans think and how they interact
with these teams and and um kind of all
of the uh the things that revolve around
sports and then all of a sudden out of
left field now comes this metaverse idea
from his son and you can just see it's
almost like he's thinking out loud and
he's trying to figure out like how is
this all going to converge but that
ultimately is where we're all headed
right
yeah
i i just think i think the fact that
we've been talking about him for a few
minutes and we haven't mentioned the
fact that he
has remarkably recovered from his
insider uh trading days what
damn coming in
he pled guilty he paid 1.8 billion false
he did not plead anything yes he did no
his firm paid okay
and he was like hey we're still boys
right
this boy was like no
he's like let me see how big the check
is listen if we're gonna talk about
martha stewart's insider trading we've
got to talk about steve cone's insider
he paid his fine um but uh
but
i think it's interesting because point
72 haven't a few of their alums gone on
to do interesting things in the crypto
space so i think like
maybe they've always been crypto curious
and now it's travis cling yeah travis
kling used to work at 0.72 now runs a uh
a hedge fund uh ikey guy asset
management
and there he's not the only one there
there's plenty of them that uh that have
done that i think also the other piece
that's really interesting about uh cohen
specifically is when he comes into a
space
he's not gonna do it with a couple of
dollars right he owns a billion dollars
of art on the conservative side
right and so you can see him nfts
metaverse crypto like like he's just
going to come in and he's going to start
playing what's up guys bang bang thanks
so much for watching the best business
show today if we're going to be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]